[Musique]
c'est la fin idéale êtes en phase orale
pour les nouvelles j'espère qu'elles
seront stationnaires braillard grande
porte à la cnas et benzema sur outils
des petites commérages eu de très grands
auteurs
le petit écho de la forêt il y à toutes
les informations à chaque nouvelle
édition on n'a jamais de déception ça
vous le découvrirez dans le tue des
coûts de l'offre
[Musique]
[Rires]
voyons voyons quelles sont les nouvelles
un max le corbeau ne veut plus se
laisser voler son fromage
je vois qu'il n'a pas oublié le bon au
tour que le mieux à jouer louis leur
honneur il y a quelques années que cela
sans vous on dirait une odeur de fromage
au salut max il fait beau aujourd'hui tu
es devenu muet
qu'est-ce que tu tiens dans ton bec
montage et cette fois ci tu ne leur a
pas max avait parlé et le fromage était
tombé dans la bouche de louis qui se
sauve en l'emportant c'est aussi j'ai
encore eu ce pauvre max quand je fus
ruses dont jean-louis caisse encore
voile et le fromage de max oui il n'est
pas en russie
trois longs traits et tosca parti le
plus vite qu'elle pût avec le fromage
qu'elle avait dérobé à louis auquel est
cette chose rond les blanches posées
devant vous et vous allez manger cette
abomination
il paraît que c'est délicieux manger ce
fromage si vous avez envie de mourir
serait-il un poison pour les tortues oui
mais je ne savais pas ce volet l'ex et
mademoiselle de la cigogne emmenait le
fameux fromage pour le savourer chez
elle mais au détour d'un chemin
mademoiselle la cigogne oui mademoiselle
slassi ryan pointu
une chose de terrible match de corbeau
est en train de manger toutes vos
graines de millet grillé quoi icipe
lelièvre d'état là le fromage en bouche
pour trouver une cachette terry
rabusseau bon appétit mon chien du vib
tu vas faire un repas de roi tout le
monde rêve est le fromage et c'est toi
qui vas tu sais moi fromage s'est créé
pour moi briffeuil a pas dû mais pour
des soucis mais je croyais que tu
verrais bien pour lui mais bien mais
boris préféré fromage se fera l'état moi
je regarde toi le garder il dit louant
l'appartement risque selon moi est très
malin non moi dévorer ses bons fromages
sûrs ou au fromage sentir bizarre qui
courra wimax beason tient watts petits
morceaux
merci marc soit est trop petit je n'ai
pas pu bien guti citons francs match
était bon on va faire
voilà autre petit bonjour merci alors
même si l'impact 6 mois par goût du
risque ce fromage avait un goût bizarre
le goût de l'eau j'ai trouvé ce fromage
avait un goût de vase et c'est ainsi que
max a réussi à manger le fromage que
louis le renard lui avait dérobé un
malin malin et demi n'est ce pas cher
téléphone alors abyei est offert amis
pour une prochaine édition du petit etc
ou de la force